[Music]
possibly hangover is limited
if you want to come next week
[Music]
but they do have our support for that if
you want to just come back and my OSB 20
September 13 to 14
here we have the class - max - the
author of area that's a 13 to 14 that
systemic poet is my heck are is they
might
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Thanks thanks everyone for coming out oh
okay yeah thanks for coming out and
thank you Jared for inviting me this
opportunity to talk so now I should say
I love something about myself because
I'm sure no one has any idea who I am
been to the meetup twice before so as
Jared said I'm coming from Berlin and
I'm here in New York for a couple of
months at a place down in lower
Manhattan called the recurse Center and
it's kind of like a programming retreat
and so I've been doing some more stuff
as well and some mix of the two and I
think we'll see a bit of that today a
mathematician by training although I
don't work as a mathematician now I was
working
I'll probably continue along that line
and so this talk is nothing to be very
mathematical but it has like a lot of
very practical and write so I think
you're gonna have a lot of doing things
and learning things together and so
there'll be some familiar things and I
think maybe some new things and
hopefully it's something that you can
use in your own work and fun because I
actually use are mostly for fun I'm not
doing going to work right now okay so
composing functions with guitars so cash
stocks is a package thyroid and actually
a new version went up on cran just today
so this is the topic I'm going to talk
about composing functions so that's okay
so I want to start with the basics like
what what is going on what I want to
mean by composing functions because it's
the center of the world so one is
composing in a mathematical sense just
chaining them together doing one
function another and so forth and the
other is composing in the sense of
writing like composing prose so writing
functions so I'm gonna talk we're gonna
talk about both aspects because they
have a lot to do with each other and I
just want to do my work this is actually
for any relevance or whatever you do
because it's something you do all the
time you're always doing this even if
you work primarily interactively and so
I
and a lot of the two minutes lies mostly
I'll just be doing things like what I
didn't practice so much but I think the
fact that I didn't practice is a
testament to the stability of idioms
what I want to present okay so first
calling functions okay something related
to compiling functions but much simpler
so what scope calling functions about
and so calling functions is something
which this thing called PI it calls me
greeter offers and it lets you basically
apply a function from right to left from
right to left and the way it works is
like did you write value and you pipe it
to a function and what this means is
you're applying X as a first argument
and then Y the second one so it's just a
reading card that reads writing card
that reads in the natural order and you
can you can go on with this you can you
can pipe one value to your function
that's that's a value and then you can
you can pass that on to another function
so G is another function and the way
what's with these operators always that
they associated to the left so first you
do this this what I showed in the
previous slide so you apply F and then
you you pipe that into Tegea and you
have that okay and you can imagine you
can do a very long chain so I think
people are most people very familiar
with this because it's very heavily
and tidy verse and for good reasons
because it's it's a very it's a very
concise way to write your code and note
one thing I didn't mention here there's
a few probably obvious if you're use
this a lot this see that F has the two
two arguments right but in in the bottom
but on the top that's just one so the
rules always that somehow the first
argument plays a special role and and
this this is very convenient because a
lot of functions kind of are set up that
way okay so this is the pipe and that's
how you use it and it's really wonderful
so the next topic is love because
everyone loves to pipe this it's very
it's a very powerful tool it's something
you don't have in Python it's kind of
actually a kind of a secret secret
weapon of our in this area and
and once you start using the pipe here
you find like uses for it everywhere so
very common as you look at code and has
like pipes all over the place and if you
use pipes before that's great because
you know what's going on you can do that
the console you can put in the function
and everything's great pipes everywhere
wonderful but it's like anything you
have too much of it can be always good
for you right like too much ice cream is
probably not good for you although ice
cream is also really wonderful so if you
use this a long enough at some point you
will notice some pain points like either
you are dead like an air or a huge stack
trace and you just don't know what's
going on or your code is somehow
mysteriously slow and Specht it's not
because you wrote that code with
something mysterious come on
okay so what's it what's going on so
let's look at this again so to keep in
mind is when you pipe things the things
on the left and the things on the right
here I'll say thanks okay it looks like
it's one thing happening another always
the same object and play but it's the
thing on the left of the valiant thing
on the red function so to make it
clearer another way to write is like
this you take this X and you pipe it
into a function so this is a dot pipe F
G is a Negrito syntax for a little
function
has one argument this dot that thought
is like a placeholder and it sends and
it does what x1 when you go back so like
what X is doing here in this line is
what the dots doing here
ok so you see there's two things going
to separate things on one is you're
composing a function that's the thing on
the right hand side in the brackets and
the value that gets pushed into so this
this god that dot doesn't do anything
it's just it's just kind of a trigger so
it's in some ways it's sort of hiding
what the relation here is here so what's
the real issue what you're actually
doing is somehow the dog is to say now
compose so why don't you just write that
and just compose so they just make up
some Alpharetta so you can go back and
it's just a C so I purposely animated
this you can see like okay the dots
disappear so basically you're just
highlighting what's actually going on
and the X in fact is a dummy variable
because it's the thing that berries okay
so X is also a dummy variable so what
you're left with is just the thing
that's doing stuff the function so the
way different that my starting point was
actually like writing this kind of
pseudocode and I started like basically
writing on paper or like typing in the
other door like actually I want to be
able to have this expressed this kind of
thing I don't want to write this door of
the X okay so this okay so this is
operator with its triple arrows is fun
compositors it takes to two functions
and it composes them should be one
function another one and it's it's an
operator that you can install from this
package called Gustad so good Gustad
it's one of those wards it actually has
a meaning in English which is kind of
close to what it means in German and it
basically means a form and structure and
also has a connotation of something
being integrated okay so you think of it
like that
so that's that's why it has this name
and so it's first of all it's not a pipe
okay so it's it's sort of it's coming
from the syntax of the pipe so kind of
fool's errand would be to say okay
Magritte a-- is wonderful but i want to
do something else and I'm gonna make up
my own notation and you guys come a long
way so it's kind of the symbol is like a
pipe but there's more of um sort of
maybe really distinctive it has a
similar syntax but it's doing something
quite different so it's not a pipe what
is it okay so I'm gonna get no okay so
that was a background the rest of the
talk is going to be mostly in our studio
doing stuff like I said I had practice
very much there could be crashes you
ready can we do this I guess I don't
have a choice
okay all right okay so let's do yeah
also the reason I want to do it not just
that it's too lazy to make slides I
think it's very useful to see like you
see code like runs on a blog or
something or or like in a package and
you don't really get an idea of like how
that was built up so the thing I want to
impress even if you kind of like forget
the details there's sort of like how do
you go about moving around in your code
and objects okay so that's the reason
I'm doing this okay
so I load up these two package so just
to give you just a reminder so so the
way the pipe works is you can take a so
for example logarithm of two is this
number but you can write it like this
I did what I wrote before and actually
you can just write logarithm right and
you can compare let's say you can do - -
oops the logarithm like absolute value
and then logarithm so that will check
out the value to in the longer than okay
same thing now so that's how piping
works very very simple so how does this
the
this composition worked well good we had
yes alright so basically okay if I write
what I had on the slide earlier it's
this alright so that thing in the
brackets is a function okay so you can
just write that function directly with
this pipe operator or sorry let's say
that again this compositor I have you
have a good name for this please tell me
cuz I I just I actually don't just type
here I never compose okay compared with
ah so it will come back to this so there
is it's just a quick side remark there's
a package called Pro that I think most
familiar with and it has a function
called compose it does composition but I
want to show you I hope to like
demonstrate with this examples is that
that function is doing things in the
wrong order like an environment in
communion order so it's like composed
but everything is going from right to
left just like piping it is from right
to left
okay so so this is a function so you
print it out it has two parts absolute
value and logarithm
and you're gonna apply sir - tutorial ok
so that's how and you can train as many
functions as you want
ok let me do like two simple like toy
examples just to show how this works so
how to make a function called scramble
and what it's going to do is good it's
going to stamp all a bunch of points and
then it's going to join them together so
collapse that sum function so if you if
you write it out put it out okay well
that's a little bit long there's the
first function is this sampling and the
next one is pasting so if I send in like
so letters letters
okay that's built-in type I scramble
letters you all just mix them up in and
paste them together if I if I can
scramble say just five of them whoops
no sorry sighs so now I took five
letters no I run it again it's just it's
random every time it's a different
example that's fine okay so that's so
that's it I could have done that with
any number of ways I could even written
it by hand
so what I really should show you two
things here which are interesting so one
is if you look at the scramble the
foremost like what are the arguments
like what does the function look like if
you are you're coming in from the
outside okay it has the same foremost it
has a sample okay so if you did the same
thing with
this migrate our pipe Oh as it pays to
collapse you're just kidding so you
don't you lose all of this okay because
it comes just a function of one variable
so I cannot do for example if I ran this
thing all right I find I can do I can do
letters that's okay by the way you just
want to do five of them so one thing is
it preserves the water function looks on
the surface and the other thing is you
can like if I run it it does something
right so this is a very simple thing and
if I print it out you can you can see
what it's doing okay what if we could
not look at this code let's just look at
it like what results is producing in the
middle so what you can do is and you can
you can write another function it was
going to be a function on function so
it's going to transform function so see
it's easier if I just write it out and
then explain how this works
come power so there's a compose function
in fish dog and it's does composition by
then left to right order so this is a
this is a function if you write it you
print it out it does two things it does
this L apply apply compose print and
then compose that's the second thing
Oh actually so a lot of times like you
print stuff out like number two the
second function is just like the source
code what is that so sometimes you just
give it a name just give it a name
composed by right
what it is and what you can do is I'm
just gonna write out show how it works
and then explain like what where is it
doing so you can you apply to scramble
you get another function okay yeah so
this outputs not very helpful but just
now look at what happens when you win
letters if you do so before we were so
let me just for okay just to emphasize
so before we're doing that now what
we're gonna do is transform scramble so
there's gonna be another function where
then we do it again and now with Prince
Arthur each step so the first step was
scramble pick five and the others next
step is placement I run it again does
the same thing so what's happening is if
you look at this step why so may bring
up the definition here was this right so
let's let's print it out stepwise so the
crucial thing is the first thing they'll
apply so what happens is you put that
dot so if you look at the he'll applies
that dots gonna be a function that you
put in you apply to that function the
composite this composition operator and
then you apply print to it so basically
what's going on is when you type
stepwise scramble okay so let me make
that so what you're actually doing is
you're doing the sample you're doing
sample and then printing and then and
then then you're composing that with
paste collapse and then you apply
printing at the end okay so now if I if
I put in say the letters here now I use
a pipe and
I apply that that vector to this
function then you get the steps you see
what's happening so what it's doing so
so this is the kind of like the first
interesting things this this function
scramble it's a function right you could
do letters it's it has parts right it
has the two parts and so it's kind of
like a list right in fact you can see
this one in the - it's sort of purposely
like what you would see if you print out
a list right you know print out a list
of prints licked your components like
that so this one of the two is very list
there's all this component so you can
act on the function like it - this so I
can do for example scramble let's take
the first function that's gonna just do
the scramble the second one is going to
be compose all right scramble had these
mini I can get anything in this case but
anyways you can you can do things like
you can scramble scramble you can just
run the components in the reverse
direction so you see now the first
component is going to be paste and the
second one is sample right because where
did I do I just reversed it two to one
so you get all these operations like
subsetting you can even do things like I
gotta take the first now so let's say
the the second thing and I'm gonna make
it say just paste okay so now when I
scramble letters size five
what does that do I think it put spaces
in between them not just spit some out
again okay so that's just a little
example of like how how does that work
is that clear I'm saying he doesn't
composing but the key is you get a
composition but it has a structure right
it's like a chain and you can kind of
like a list so writing writing sample
whatever paste you think of this as
writing something like list sample paste
okay so in fact I could finally just
apply components to that list and I
cannot get it so sort of everything like
this intuition of function chains was
sort of like Chinese people together
like Liz so they act like they do behave
like that they're not list but you can
treat them like that okay just one other
like real quick example cuz it's kind of
fun you can you can even do very
sophisticated things very very concisely
if you don't if you're not always trying
to extract this like X or this point so
high for example you can you can like
tabulate primes already to view what you
do is you just take say yeah I'd say I
want to do I want to do something like
primes 10 100 and I want that to print
out like the first the primes up to 100
so the one way you can do it is you just
you just take so so let's do it like
this I'm going to build it up in pieces
so I have the first part which is just
take the take a sequence of things then
you cut off then what you do is you cut
off the ones so you take the tail all
right okay so now I do Prime's of ten I
just get to two and then the next thing
you do is
then you have to find out like which of
these numbers are products oh by the way
prime numbers are numbers which are not
they are only divisible by 1 and itself
and the next step is you can do
something like well I will have the
range and I want to find what are all
the products of those numbers in the
range and that this operation called
outer product so it's this operator if
you've never seen this percent and look
it up it's quite useful so now if I do
prime 6 times 10 then it will compute
the range and this this matrix is our
product outer products and then the last
thing I the only thing I need to do now
it so you see how I'm building it up I'm
like starting with goodbye bid on just
filling out the function now I'm going
to compose the last part and you will be
take their range and the products and so
I take the range and I want to filter
out I want to filter out the range the
those things in the range that are not
products that's a crime right so that so
that's how you get one way to compute
prize because not very vicious but just
to give you an example I'm gonna when I
see you like okay have you did all this
stuff what did we do I'm gonna print it
out and you can do all sorts of things
like cutting and cut this function just
look at what happened
I did it power how I see okay let's just
do that those other primes - okay so
calm down just like it's like how did
you retail things in an environment so
you just kind of like guess like what ll
do based on what you know we put them
and typically we'll do that okay
so that was just like I would all taste
of what's going on here okay so like I
said I just want to do a little fun
examples they are mostly not my card so
that's the real hard part I didn't write
the con so I guess it's real the other
one it's the next example of the game of
life so the game of life is it's what's
called a cellular automaton let me want
to just run the movie to show you so
what's happening is you have this grid
as he squares and there's kind of like
walking and the rule is that if you
changing and they're growing and the
other thing is well cell is good
surrounded by too many yellow things it
also dies it's get suffocated and it's
kind of like a Goldilocks number of
neighborhoods and then a yellow cell
will persist also like an empty Aria
blue
blew into Serena by Bruno the life can
arrive by the blue is surrounded by the
right number of yellow things then it
will kind of like come to life and so
that's kind of the rules of the game
going on like this and it's not like in
space invaders if you go to the right on
the left so how does this work is this
is this code if it is not all right this
isn't a written in a language called APU
health called a programming language or
take so actually a lot of inspiration
from this language now this kind of code
is basically inscrutable but at some
point you're kind of like I understand
something there are a lot of interesting
ideas that fall under don't take this
card or like the idea of this code and
show how you can like implement this
game basically I'm like four lines of
code it's very simple and the point is
like the goal is not write short code
because short code is never a goal you
want your card code to be readable and
ideally it should be fast but brevity
just for brevity sex is not
okay so alright get my bike so how does
this work so this is the next example
so here oh by the way okay okay okay
okay
so the way it works is you make these
they said these this this grid it's a
matrix it's a boolean matrix right
yellow is true blue is false so I
prepared like two matrices here so one
called sales in the world so if you look
at sales it's this and world is a bigger
thing so I made some with all utility
functions to plot this because looking
at this doesn't tell you anything so we
can just show sales it's this metric and
show world and it's that thing it's it's
basically the same same one but embedded
in a larger world okay so to do that
sorry
mai-chan on something like they were
just maybe very bad idea like before us
setting up my computer actually had the
card for this year at my I do I thought
very funny but I could just try the
recruiting so it could be that I so this
is a number of helper functions so I
just wrote this over my heart
yeah head of time cuz I would it doesn't
add in
to the talk just to do this by hand so
let me explain what's going on and so
there's you have this you started
duration and you had to find out like
what are the neighbors of all the points
and the basic idea is that followed you
take care of starting configuration and
you translated in all the eight
directions okay so and so you there's a
one function that will specify all the
directions that's something called tied
to find here it's called square okay so
you give it a so you give it like minus
one to one and it's just going to give
you all pairs of numbers from minus one
to one so that's that will give you like
all the sort of Direction vectors for
the neighbors and then there's a
function called translate and it will
just shift an image around so for
example if I if I translate sales by the
vector like one down and one down and
one across okay whoops let me do it the
other one let me do let me do world and
I want to show the world so so watch
carefully it's gonna move right so this
translation does this moving so you
their logic is this you just take your
computer initial configuration you move
it around okay in all their positions
and also the starting position button
you just add up how many neighbors their
work and that that should give you that
should determine the rule for the next
step in the evolution so how do we write
this so it's a bit easier if i switch
now to
yeah okay let me go open up a new window
so it's this life thing is good they
spent two components which is one is you
let's see I guess you you count your
counting neighbors so I don't I don't
know what that's gonna be penny let's
just fill it in with some dummy function
[Music]
that's basically roughly that how it's
gonna work
right you count based on the count you
you've all so there's a life it just has
to part has these coupons just identity
function so I said what we're gonna do
is we're gonna just like where we're
doing with the primes just like filling
the pieces so it's just kind of like
scaffolding see this this thing you were
just like hanging markers there ok so
right now for example if I looking at
life evolved right so sup sup in there
it's just nothing just didn't function
so the first step in there so let's try
to figure out what that first thing is
so life count so we're gonna sign it the
function that basically takes yourself
okay as the first thing and then it's
going to account it's gonna count them
so it's gonna do something you had to
apply another function to the cell so
like something like
neighbors okay and I'm going to I want
this to be a composite function so I'm
gonna do a ploy a trick where I can just
compose against now and that will just
make a composite composite function so
that I can use this
Magritte are like syntax see that dot
that's like them agreed our dog okay
beside them agree rules for how the dog
behaves in the Magritte or prizes
example if you film your toes if you put
a if an argument matches got exactly
than the dot you don't have okay if you
look at all account it's just that one
function okay what is the count neighbor
it's now you have to count the neighbors
so so live so the second part is going
to be count you're gonna do something
like this function will be well you okay
let me use a send syntax
wait so we ever we have a list with
names and in that context want to apply
to logic of the game for these cells and
the count of the cells so the rule for
this game is if the count if the count
is three you live okay or if the count
is four and the cells are alive you also
live so this second line is is a rule of
the game and
and I can pose again with okay so now
everywhere you have is look at live
count the second part it's just this
function that see with the width you can
see this little dot yeah they just got
inserted we didn't write that
but it got inserted because that's
that's that's the syntax for the pipe
operator and therefore also to the
comparator okay now if you run this on
the cells okay great
do it okay know why it doesn't work
okay well something's not working well
actually if you look at it it's this
this cow thing we never defined it so
really now we have to define these how
do you count the neighborhood well
that's what I was that's what this
picture was showing right you just like
translate the square round and then you
just count them okay so you do so the
live what do I call it make this
copy/paste account oh by the way so let
me really like just so everything fits
on
so count neighbors your what you're
gonna do is you you take this square
like all the directions that's this
square right so if I write the square
these are all the directions so I'm
gonna like I have to map over the
directions and translate so I just
literally write back
so map over the directions I translate
it and translate translate as a
translate is a function translate X by a
certain amount so that the thing that
I'm translating is the X and I purposely
put in the second place so I can just
put a point here and then the next step
is we just add everything so the way you
do read I addition like a bunch of
matrices you can apply the sub function
you have to do a reduction put the plus
sar you you reduce with plus okay that
make sense okay let's so let's let's
look at it again
so count count neighbors is also
composite function and has two parts one
is you map over at the directions your
map translation the function of our
directions and you translate the dot
which is the thing that we're gonna feed
into cells and then you just add
everything up because it's a boolean
matrix so when you add get scores to
integer and you get the count so now if
we use every
so we have all the pieces here right
except the girl but you've all this
power that's why I don't work so life
evolve
has to be let me just write it out
quickly sales is three or sells is four
and no not the sales
[Music]
let's see already calling it before okay
so all the order got all screwed up okay
let's do it again so that's done okay so
count one okay so this yeah they're like
cuttings it always happens and so the
first thing has you you need to count
things so you you collect the cells and
you take out other cells which is this
count neighbors of the cells and then so
this is this we called count before and
then the next thing is we want to evolve
okay just giving it a name and there was
this with with mines are gonna copy and
paste it right okay so why can I have
the two parts I know this has too many
parts okay this is great cuz you want to
get rid of some of this stuff what are
we doing in a bun so you can just true
we can just three take live count count
there we want to get rid of that so just
get rid of it okay so you got rid of it
now if the names are kind of messed up
oh I call rid of the wrong thing okay
count evolve okay when I get rid of that
[Music]
now okay let me just do it from scratch
I got tasted that all right okay so this
should be okay now
so let's see all right so now what we
want first you want to count like this
so look at first functions is counting
things why is it called it hard okay so
we have to decide to do one thing here
which is okay so this is actually good
that so many things are going wrong
because you can see how to fix it so
what I want to do is I want to take a
function and I want to call it so how's
the names have to match so I have to
call cells the dot and count has to be
count neighbors I've got okay
all right because you're fine okay
so with basically just it just assumes
these names in the list okay it says
you'd instead of writing dollar signs
you can just write them me
so if you okay let's try this out on the
cells so it sends everything to zero
which is a little bit strange
let's let's try that on the world
let's look at what it is how that worked
I don't know why I did it so let's uh
let's let's apply it so let's do this so
you take the world let's apply a 1
iteration so that's that do another one
so forth and I have a little function
that does an animation and so let's okay
sorry beforehand I made a little
animation function basically what it's
doing is it's just it's just going to
it's just gonna apply this life function
again and again and again and I keep
displaying these things so I know I
animate the world and I just start doing
those so it's just applying life again
and again and again okay so there were
there a lot of little bumps from the
road buddy the point is not like death
things right the first time it's just
going to see the flow you can kind of
like build things up in pieces and
things gonna have names and you can
expect them just just just so that we
can move on to another more interesting
example this is the Chi isn't the end of
the things because now you see the
output but you might want to know like
what is this counting actually doing and
you can you can you can see that it just
just there
[Music]
okay so just just to show you well
that's too bad because that I find to
either the function okay let's just move
on to the example I just say it in
rewards so yeah I said in pictures like
the logic is you move this cells around
in your count so I just said that and I
implemented it but you never saw
directly what was happening in the
intermediate step but in fact if you
write out your function in these
composable pieces you can you can kind
of short-circuit it you can just say
like just show me what the two first two
steps are and so you can inspect that's
in between kind of like what we saw with
this scrambling okay so that's okay so
okay so next example is something with
Traveling Salesman so that's all of you
took them in and then repurpose them for
illustration purpose so this example
image and then when you do is you
transform it into one of these
illustrations you ever see where you you
draw a picture with a pencil but you
don't lift the pencil off the paper and
it's like all these squiggly message so
you can you can kind of compute that and
what you do is so it's
with all program by this guy Antonio
Sanchez you took a picture a sampled a
bunch of points basically the dark
points and then fine found a path
through all those points like a single
one path and is what's called Traveling
Salesman problem where you have a bunch
of points and you want to find kind of
like a shortest path that will go okay
so so this is an interesting example of
where I took just to show you like how
does that life thing we did from scratch
well what if we took like someone else's
code
that doesn't use this composition like
how can it
how can it be transformed so that's this
thing Frankenstein so this code here so
let me just run it I believe it should
ok I I don't like this and it takes like
a minute it's doing in the window it's
just doing what I said it just samples
points find the path every time you get
like a slightly different picture doing
random sampling
it's knowledge that's what it's these
little points finding a path right so
this is an example okay first of all
it's like a really cool thing and
secondly like the way the guy wrote it
is a very like standard way I guess the
way people use pipes and when you shoot
with the pipes that you can get very
long that's not really good man
pipe is kind of a nice arrangement but
there isn't one problem with the pipe
that that nice a chain that you can
follow from left to right that wonderful
but it's sort of frozen your source code
you can't do anything with it it's just
it's just the way the right source code
it's not a way you not you cannot act on
that structure they just your the pipe
does compute it consumes it and produces
a value okay so let's do the following
so I'm you show you how you can let's
try to do this together so I probably
will get something wrong but show you
how you can take this transformation of
values and and turn that into an
operation by a function so you'll see
how there's this sort of a syntax it
between the composition operator and
pipe match and and also how you you kind
of change your perspective a little from
values to functions okay
it's a function okay so there one thing
is so we're gonna need I'm just gonna go
here so this is like one of those TV
shows or someone goes
that's like a makeover you can do
anything up
oh yeah like messy you buy I mean and
everything it's nice
so if internews you're watching this
awesome work forgive me for this
illustration okay so let me let's do a
fresh start gonna respect the session so
I'm just gonna load okay so up to this
point I can just run that that's that's
just loading libraries okay this part so
you did well let's go through the card
really quickly so what's it what's
happening as you this data obviously
explain what's going on the data the
main thing is this thing sample take a
picture basically itís a huge matrix
sample points you get a table okay so
this bit is gonna be a table next point
next step take take this data and then
so these points and then find a path
through the parts so it's called
solution but somehow it's like computing
roots
okay this path the other thing then the
next thing is oh sorry and what are the
points according to like the the the
ordering in the past okay sorry I'm
gonna take a data plan and I'm gonna get
a subset that rows by this thing called
solution okay and the last thing is just
appalling so the last thing is not
there's nothing you have a data friend
at points and you're basically joining
up all the point that is that clear like
whatever the details are that's
basically what it to know one thing you
should notice is they're all these
comments
comments are wonderful but actually you
don't need them yeah well it wouldn't it
be better if your code actually to tells
you what it's doing and you don't have
these comments around that so we already
saw that before and so what I'm gonna do
is we have this image so first thing is
bad get rid of that line because that
imagery without that dummy like this dot
this X is the pipe that's just a dummy
variable so the first thing is find a
name caller like sample sample pixels
cuz this is what the first step is to
but sampling pixels the next thing is
you then change all of its all of these
pipes to these compositors okay this is
a very mechanical I could do such
another place but I just feel like that
okay and and then that's like also we
can structure it like let's give this
thing a name this is called grayscale
this second part is threshold so I give
it a name let's just give it a name here
and then the last part is sampling so
here is you actually do the sampling
let's just give that that okay the
structure is like that I'm just giving a
min so it's the same thing
pipes go to compare compositors I've
sort of grouped things according to what
they're doing
sorry we don't need this common anymore
because I already I know attributed and
so unless if you run run this function
row
what the hell oh it's syntax error so if
something is not lining up
[Music]
that's more cosmetic it's let's go okay
that's good I don't know
so let's look quickly at standby view
view printout sample pixels it's gonna
be even your thoughts know what your
parts but you can look at the you know
the names of of sample pixels has like
this grayscale threshold sample and the
first part is this is just taking
grayscale there's two parts to it oh
it's just one part turn okay so that's
the first part we actually done with
that let's finished the car to the next
one so that's one is now your it's
called solution but what we're doing is
now we're finding the route
now you got the points now find a route
let's call this route okay and this is
done
and actually what we're doing is you're
us we're computing the distance and then
we're flying this traveling salesman
problem algorithm sorry get rid of this
yeah and everything gets changed to this
compositor and as in a jerk and yeah
everyone I guess we can annotate this
just leave it like that okay so that's
that's a function we don't notice that
nothing in here we have to change if we
just change all the pipes syntax design
so now so we got that function route
like has all these parts let's go on to
the next point so the next part is where
we are actually watering all those
points so now we comes the tricky part
which is always
finding a good nanny for things
and I don't know a good name but it's
cuz you're kind of like I thought we
already got the right now we're gonna
call this weird again No
so here's what we can do you know
yesterday when you write a function this
is very common you write like I'll make
a whole bunch of assignments do stuff
right so you can do the same thing here
right with our routing function just you
know that block where you make all those
assignments that's basically a local
environment you can capture that as a
function so in this Gestapo
Christoff package you have a function
that does that and it's called that so
you could do things like the following
I'm gonna let so the pixels pixels
equals or so that you may see so we
start with the image okay
and so it's where you should be thinking
of this as if you're writing a function
like and I'm making assignments like I
do one if I'm a national next thing is
when you find you sample the pixels
alright so we did this by sample pixels
pixels the image okay this image is that
image there not notice them I'm putting
it on there and then the next step is we
find me to calculate the route the route
is just going to be the root of the
sample all right there's a next time
and finally we make the picture so let's
call it picture and the picture is doing
this thing so that kind of solves our
name problem so what we do is we take
the date the data that I was the what
will be gone out of sample pixels so
it's going to be a sample and the
solution with what we called root so you
just do this alright okay so let's call
this
no portrait okay so we're gonna get
again and this is going to be the first
part of a composite function so we're
just gonna just saw like what we've been
doing all along instead of like W just
we have one powers you know and
something else comes later we don't I
really no actually we know what's gonna
come next we're gonna plot and let's
just so what happens if we do portrait a
portrait of the image that we start out
with so it's remembering me just this
omission of the Frankenstein and if we
do your portrait of the image and didn't
actually it just just prints out like
what the computation is it doesn't
actually do anything it's lazy so it's
just sort of like showing you what you
want to do you intend to do this so you
intend to do didn't take image sample
computer route computer picture but
nothing actually happened
if you like a portrait portrait the
second part plot it's just either new
functions not really play okay so now we
have to actually do the plotting so just
like there's let let that like bundles
all those assignments they're like lazy
assignments and there's the once you
have those assignments like in a
function now go do something like take
that picture so so there's the an okay
once you do that you run it so you let
em use equals this example you close
this and so forth take all of that stuff
and then run so it's called run so you
support range what we're gonna do is
we're gonna take the
portraits everyone we just want to
change the plot part and we're gonna
make it okay let me do it
actually let's just do it here because I
heard it done for us so that's the all
this part yeah
I can get rid of all that we already so
this data solution that's sample route
here and this plot part is basically
this I've just try to put it in there
okay that's not gonna work so we have to
run the thing sorry
so let's so what is what I'm gonna do
what do we want to run data plot no cuz
dinner part is not an object that exists
anymore
that didn't apply with this picture
today different so we want to we want to
pop a picture and then everything is to
say so the exit and why are they in the
picture okay okay portrait so everything
is perfect so okay let's let's take
let's back up and recap what we do
before we have nothing is computed here
these are just functions no values okay
there's no data for any image this will
work for any image if it works at all
for anything to draw a lot go for work
do something so so we defined always so
we just took each of the steps converted
them to functions and then we now we
have a function but that does has two
parts it just takes everything that we
have this is the business logic come in
father
okay so let's let's try that portrait
okay so if they walk you know like take
a little time and then like I know you
all keep going forever I have something
already start looking at some water I
have I have a let's see let me let's try
another so I downloaded a so I gonna
start studio you have the terminal
I have an Elvis picture now this JPEG
okay I guess I could copy it here okay
let's try that and now let's go back to
the console so let me let me do
partridge
this guy I believe this one work so well
do something so for Frankenstein maybe I
caught it
by the way you have no idea what the
Elvis looks like but I think you can get
my right yes it's like just like the
original okay all right sorry so just a
recap see so you so what did we do
always nothing okay this is the thing
how much we did nothing just like
changing parts to composite earth we
didn't throw them out when you replace
them kind of a comment nicer than
comments you can actually like subset
this function on that moon more useful
like reference point and this part here
so normally you would have written this
function like this you would write
function blah blah blah and an image dot
sample and so forth and then plot so
that's fine but I realize if you do
things basically you're locking all of
your logic and your computation in the
function you can't go in and pull
something out so for example in this
portrait right
do you write a function all that logic
that's just that's just in there trapped
and you got the copy and paste go in the
editor change things create a function
do things start over again
that's very if you write the function
portrait like this it has the two two
parts all right the first part and the
second parts plot so the second part so
a portrait plot was the plotting part
like this GG plot stuff you can do
things like you can understand what's
even going on here so for example we
didn't be like you just see the finish
result okay okay typically but you also
want to know how did I get there and is
that correct
how can I know it the correct so you
always want to have some way to inspect
now typically you just look at source
code you kind of like do some kind of
hard copy paste and inspect objects this
way but because this function itself is
decomposable you don't have to cut away
your source code you can just cut this
function and run the function so for
example this is like tracing out these
this car where is it spotting you know
how'd you tell and like what does it
look like to do like 2,000 of these
points alright so you can what you can
do is I have time for this but this
number here 8,000
this is something that you can thousand
becomes a number like 10 points and then
you're a very end points and then see
how that how that thing works and you
can you can you read you want to try
that I actually never tried this one
yeah yeah so you can do that sure so for
example we this portrait so you look at
portrayed the first part which was just
those bindings right it has it image the
sample the route and the picture right
so let's take say let's see like what is
this route for example if you're
interested let's do this so this will be
an example of inspection
well that's let's see what does the
picture look like after 4,000 points so
it doesn't 8,000 what about 4,000 so
what you can do is so we have to change
this thing yeah so okay there's gonna be
a little bit so we take the first part
and we apply image to it okay that's
just what we did now what we want to do
is we just want to take the picture part
of the picture so we take run the
picture but maybe just take the first to
fourth which 4001 all right
okay and then let's plot that
see what happened probably those just to
do something okay let's try that and
then we do portrait so the portrait
hasn't only works on something called
picture so we have to know pipe this
into a picture you close that thing and
then and then so now we're applying a
value so I'm just using the pipe and now
I apply well the pipe is kind of weird
so I have to do brackets here okay we
don't have to do that and then I take no
picture no sound
okay so let's see what happens maybe
this step is bad picture
okay so we can take the picture and
let's take the first 4,000 points and
then let's
[Music]
[Music]
that's like part of the picture you see
no it didn't start down there if you
look at this - like super messy but the
boiler is the midpoint you know it's try
to trim any sauce cause everything is
there and all you like the flow for
analyzing data okay so actually had some
other examples picture a good picture
like what this is and kind of how you
use it is function so I won't go into
that but if you look at the reasoning
for the picture that is an example there
even if you just want to use the pipe to
compute a value like one time get that
value you can go on it's still useful to
consider that as a composition of
functions and so the reason make totally
explain like what you
we skip that demo okay so you can
install it this a new version that's on
crayon today and you can look at the
repo which has more examples yeah you
want me to go back to that slide
this is here how in our studio yeah so I
did okay so the examples I did were okay
so for example you can you can do this
you can do you can do these functions
like this in the greeter but this thing
okay let's listen but you can't do
anything with this really like you can
like it's always just gonna be a
function of the one door actually this
works but why does is not surprising
yeah but man at my art studio crash yeah
okay was it something with the pipe or
with the composite
oh yeah yeah did something like maybe
you'd do something like this car with
the sample yeah yeah yeah yeah so
because see this this thing here is a
function so now we apply the function
yeah so so this is why so yeah the pipe
okay so they say yes okay last film in
point if you want to call functions use
the pipe
do you want to composite function so you
can do you can do this you can call it
like that and then everything is left to
right yeah that's just a regular that's
just regular calling calling
okay so I assure you very quickly so the
question was like why compose from left
to right well one answer is because
McGruder doesn't but the actual answer
is because lists go from left to right
so for example if I had to have a
function like I do absolute value then
log may be identity just for fun
functions are three things like this I
could convert it to a list I get a list
and then if I compose that I should get
back the same thing I get back the same
thing
sorry if you're winning the other way
around then the order would be reversed
because the okay so let's look at this
function f right because one is absolute
value then logarithm then identity so if
you convert that to a list should
maintain that order absolute value
logarithm identity and then if you
compose it
you should give maintain that same order
so if I you know compose it I should
again absolute value logarithm I don't
if it went the other way around every
time you do one operation the other
you'd have to reverse compose
yeah so the what I read somewhere is
happy Wickham saying something like the
the possum was a mistake than I was
before plus is a kind of historical
artifact it was before this pipe the
pauses during the pipe but it only makes
sense in the ggplot so you cannot
replace that plaster with anything else
it has a special meaning you so the way
the plus works is when you make a ggplot
object it's taking that plus and
interpreting everything in a special
ad-hoc environment where that plus is
doing composition so you cannot like
okay give you an example if I do ggplot
ggplot cars all right and then plus GM
points okay that works yeah but if I do
this kind of nuisance but it's probably
gonna stay like that forever because did
you call it super complicated in I never
did that it's probably do nothing but
let me try it I have no idea I think you
will just break well sure
I apply this yeah well no I didn't know
okay maybe a good point I thought they
were definitely be garbage but I don't
know if this is garbage this is Oh Oh do
this okay okay okay let's do this let's
do this okay
okay thank you for this question it's a
good lad in my opinion it's one of the
more interesting things because what the
LED is doing is the following so it's a
better easier for me to write oh yeah
so when you're writing a function like I
don't know dot dot or like X you do
something like wise logarithm of X and
that is equal to X plus y and then W is
equal to Y times ad and then finally you
do W squared like a function looks like
this right you make a bunch of these
definitions and what the letters doing
is like this part so let me do it let me
put everything here and brackets what
the letters is doing it's capturing this
part and the function and then taking it
out of the function so the point there
is so I can write something like y
equals logarithm of X well I just take
the whole thing again oops okay all
these become equal signs and they called
it the pekka's are called contents and
if I run this it didn't work as a syntax
error oh yeah thank you
so if I run this I get this context all
right it's just like I named promises
if I run the context and I try to
extract within these say why okay it's
not gonna work because there's no Hicks
but if I say like X is one and then now
I run it well that's something no let's
try W what that basically what the
context is doing is it's you're gonna go
back here it's capturing all of this
environment which you can move around
and reuse so for example if I had
another function like like like this and
let me call it G everything was the same
except the last line was like W plus W
all this stuff is repeating so capturing
all of these assignments through the
let's this contacts just lets you repeat
it so what you can do is you can write
then this app you can sort of write in
this you're right you take this well
this is not a function but if I put a
dot in here say let's let's do let's
stir like this and then I buy composer
with run that context say W squared okay
that's a function and if I run that
again say like Y and it should do Y is 1
this X that's why it's
this is why I call that a dot I only do
it now then you're all you got Transpac
give you for one because well why is one
set is 2 and then 2 times 1 is 2 and the
y squared and I get 4 all right you see
this the thing is this context this this
thing that function sure there's local
variable they're not captured in a
function I can reuse it because I can
just compose it with another function so
if I had the G I can just make like G's
gonna be the first part of that and then
now I run like 5 times W ok so that so 5
times 30 squared so I should give you 27
the G have all the same assignments why
am i repeating this so let me just catch
it as a function I repurposed that so
basically this is what I meant in the
beginning by training functions and also
like composing like how you write it
so this is pros and you write in the
function that's actually decomposable
you just have to find like one of the
boundaries of the chunks you want to
compose cut them out yeah like a little
to open the package like a lab component
and then take those pieces and you can
put them together so it's not as macho
arises these objects that I trapped in
your source code
they're just as a part of your question
of other lads like what it's
you don't there's many ways to do it you
can definitely do it that way too you
can send me my so the point of the left
is you so when you make a silence so the
point of the Fineman it's exactly
alright so I'm making I'm finding these
names and that expressions that come
after I use those names I came before
alright so you just take a bunch of
functions and they have like some formal
arguments that are some whatever name
they are and you have to make sure you
are matching all those names but if
you're in a situation where you already
know how things are lined up then you
can you can do you can just pick the
names that you want so you're you're
right that like each of these lines
could be a separate function and you can
change many things together but look at
what's happening you're gonna be
collecting you're gonna could you you
you've compute one thing
okay pass one thing in compute it get
another one carry those two things
around for one it sends the wide to
visit tip is that okay now you have X
why's that so you gotta carry those
around so you can imagine even if you
compose them and you video pieces where
each expression is a little function and
yeah if the thing that you want to do
kind of like uses everything you got a
call around the let just lets you do it
in like one call rather than like a
whole bunch of nested
[Music]
[Applause]